Kimberly McIntosh you've you've written
pretty extensively about your search not
from mr. right but from mister walk tell
me about that I mean what does that mean
yeah I'm still on the lookout by the way
and for someone still haven't met
someone yet so open for invitations
auditions all of it but it's such a mr.
work so work means kind of being in tune
with the social justice issues of the
day about inequality about human rights
and I have to disclaimer that in the day
I do research on race and inequality
so those issues are really important to
me but I am also really fun at a party
as well I am so concerned but I mean
you're you're you're pretty candid about
some of you know earlier sexual
experiences yeah
and there was and there was one that
would quit which stuck with me and
indeed in the first mr. walk article
where you you were about to lose your
virginity and your prospective partner
said he'd never had sex with a black
girl before so I just I put a stop to
that encounter actually I lost my
virginity to someone else in the end he
didn't say that
and bit of a late bloomer say University
was the place but it was very
off-putting but it's also quite a common
thing to happen for quite a lot of black
women what tell us a bit more about that
you experienced that and why this this
this search for a mr. walk you know it
isn't perhaps as kind of weird given
your experiences yes I'm definitely and
from the responses that I've got and
it's definitely I'm not the only person
that's had some of these experiences so
for example when I was on study abroad I
hooked up with this guy who is American
and I found out that actually he is what
we'd call a biological racist so he
believes that like some races are just
predisposed to violence for example or
have certain behaviors that he did think
that about black people but not about me
as an individual which is always I find
interesting they always the dissonance
there doesn't make someone necessarily
change their view so he actually said to
me oh but you're not like that and I was
like well yeah of course not and no one
is no one's innately
but it didn't result in him then
evaluating his views what did he just
think that you were a you were an
exception yeah an exception to a rule
yeah I make better choices now I meet
much nicer people than that I have to
admit reading the articles it does sound
like you've met a series of you know
bits of work frankly I mean tell us a
little bit more about some of your
experiences I mean it was a there was a
there was a boyfriend that you had then
went to India who who decided to get in
touch he went on a holiday and it was
reflecting a lot about our relationship
we've been broken up for like over a
year at least and then he just sent me
this really out of the blue weird like
pseudo intellectual analysis about race
and gender and how you know there was I
was obsessed with it apparently obsessed
with his view in a sense was that you
viewed everything through through the
prism of race yeah through the prism of
race and gender but race the most and
the at first used to think why why would
I do that all the time particularly
because I grew up in Redding which is
like a small town and have lots of white
middle-class friends so you know what
did I have to complain about why I was
always talking about race all the time
and he did acknowledge that that was
probably a bit unfair but race
unfortunately is I mean I'm proud of Who
I am but even in the places where I
don't want it to be an issue it still is
unfortunately we live in a country where
44% of people believe that some races
are born harder working than others so
these ideas haven't gone away and until
they have like I'm going to have to keep
talking about it and it has to keep
being part of my life and I hope that
one day our society is one where these
issues don't matter and I'm out of a job
and I think of something else to
complain about but we're not there yet
and and he couldn't really get that or
see that let's go through the walk
checklist that you have and whether or
not it's written down in a bit of heat
but it does strike me that you probably
have no given you experience
a list of things that you won't tolerate
anymore what would be on that list so
definitely you know no racists no sexist
no one who's homophobic these are like
you know pretty standard for me too yeah
I'm glad those like the basic things you
need to care about what's happening in
wider society it needs to bother you the
poverty has increased that child poverty
has increased social issues have to
matter to you in some way otherwise it's
just not going to work and yeah you know
some people might find that a bit much
someone in when I wrote like an
amalgamation of these articles in a
piece for The Guardian some of the
comments underneath for saying good luck
in life love you know maybe just get
some cats I don't think this guy exists
okay would could you for example you
know and be in a longer-term
relationship with someone who didn't
believe just by way of example that the
Metropolitan Police were institutionally
racist for me no and I think you can
take people on a journey if you're
willing to do that people are always
willing to learn and change and if you
really love someone people can be
willing to put in that kind of work but
I'm tired I can't I just I don't want to
know there's always the risk that that
view might never change and then you
could have invested a year and someone
who ultimately is never gonna see the
world the way that you see it but you
can't agree on everything
otherwise they wouldn't yeah I think
there are some things that are
fundamental for me and they really
matter you can overlook things for a
while but I think in the long term
people values matter if it's where you
work it's you hang out with and
definitely who you have a relationship
with I think sharing values is really
important so is there a problem in
particular two white men I think white
men do you have a lot of wets do and one
of the others
I've gotten his was just like stop
dating white man they were just like
just stop because it's clearly just
loads of bother and you did do you did
they're actually yeah I did it from some
white men had a bit of a rest yeah to
recover from the last from the last few
guys but I did take a break for a bit
and it was a nice rest but we live in a
country that is 85% white and I live in
a city that's also deeply unequal and
work in industries work which were also
really deeply unequal so outside of apps
on the day-to-day I am mostly meeting
white man and I'd like to give people a
chance I don't think you should just
write people off immediately do you
understand
and this this will refer to people who
don't know the backstory who haven't
read the articles about your search for
mister walk but do you understand why
eyebrows might immediately be raised at
a statement like yeah I'm taking a break
from from white men I mean if the
situation were turned and I said yeah
I'm taking a break from break from black
women guys there are too many issues
around it
I would be pilloried and I'm probably
rightly so yeah definitely and I think
particularly when you're talking about
race like making any blunt statement it
cuts pretty hard but and even with wider
issue say like terms like white
privilege or talking about black lives
matter I think when I'm saying I'm
taking a break from white man I'm not
saying all white men are awful and and
these are traits that every white man
shares because they're innate to them
but definitely not it's more that we
live in a society where for a lot of
people think you know racism is over or
that's a thing of the past and people
very rightly want to just get on with
their lives and their families and don't
necessarily find wider social issues
that interesting unless it's directly
affecting them and that's okay but that
does mean that for me it's just a bit
harder to meet someone who is both the
white man and shares those values and
believes that
is still a really serious problem it's
not saying that I would never date white
men again or I think that they're all
evil and terrible and the source of all
of our issues not at all but does ever
does the thought ever cross your mind
you mentioned the comment you know under
the Guardian article do you know what
you know good luck you you'll struggle
to find I mean do you ever think do you
know what maybe this this might not work
that there might not be the guy who
takes all of these boxes out there I
mean no one will be perfect I'm you know
hugely imperfect I mean so it also got
to consider that someone has to part
with me and my cavernous floors as well
I've not under the belief that I'm some
ideal partner and I don't think anyone
will ever be completely perfect for
someone and you have to change and make
space for people and grey with them but
equally there are some values that I
think that I have that are deeply held
and I think everyone has those mine just
might be slightly different to other
people's which we talked about some of
those and whether or not they actually
are again you know deal-breakers for you
when it comes to comes to a relationship
I mean a phrase which many people will
have had but perhaps less than that
number will understand is its cultural
appropriation
I mean first and foremost before we get
into the nitty-gritty I mean could you
could you have a long-term relationship
with someone who didn't think that
cultural appropriation was a thing yeah
I probably could I mean if that's the
only it depends what you mean by isn't a
thing because I think there are actually
some valid criticisms of cultural
appropriation not as an idea but as it
being like the most important issue
about race that we should be talking
about right let's not let's sort the
documents and then what what is cultural
appropriation so cultural appropriation
and I see if there's kind of two strands
of it so there's the really clear one
which I think most people would agree is
not good where people use symbols or
clothing that's really sacred to a
particular group almost maybe to a
religious or spiritual level so for
fancy-dress putting on a Native American
headdress and people from that community
saying this is deeply integral part of
our culture
you know it has spiritual value to worse
and you wearing it as a costume for like
a bit of fun on Halloween is very
offensive to us and I think a lot of
people can get behind thinking okay
that's bad you know if someone was
Christian for example and said that
there was something that they felt was
sacred to them and said please don't
wear that is some kind of joke that
people could understand why that might
be the case that people would be against
that but I think there is another strand
of cultural appropriation which is a lot
more difficult and it blurs into the
kind of cultural exchange and sharing
because no one wants to live in a
society where you know no one can be
influenced or learn from another culture
cuz that'd be really boring
well it strikes me of the history of art
is in essence what cultural
appropriation by there on these terms
definitely but I think most of the
complaints around when people are
talking about cultural probation for
those kinds of things so say having cane
rows or coronaries depending on whether
you're north american or what part of
the caribbean you're from but and a
particular hairstyle that becoming
popular because lots of white women on
instagram have it i think the real issue
and it always is the same issue really
is about power so it's not that people
are really upset about someone having
the hairstyle it's more that in the same
society in which we live people who've
been wearing that hairstyle for their
whole lives because it's an easy way to
maintain your hair in that style and it
looks cool have been criticized or you
know told that they look messy or been
discriminated against in the workplace
and I think if we didn't have that in
our society then we wouldn't have this
anger about a Kardashian having hair
implants it's more than the praise that
comes with that it's like wow she's so
new and edgy and different and
interesting for doing this whilst say a
black woman could do the same thing and
be told you know all that doesn't really
fit
with our dress code here or be called
ghetto or something like that so it's
more about unfairness rather than not
wanting to share cultures I mean so do
you think that there are there are any
circumstances in which white people
can't for example wear dreadlocks I'm
gonna use the example Justin Bieber for
example you look do you believe honestly
believe that the majority of black
people who saw Justin Bieber with
dreadlocks went this is cultural
appropriation please get hands off my
culture and this is a there's a power
imbalance here or do you not just think
they looked at and thought you look like
a bit of an idiot you know not mutually
exclusive I think people are able to
think both things at once like not only
do you look like an idiot but this is
kind of irritating maybe they wouldn't
use the words cultural appropriation
because I do think that is a very like
small group of Millennials that you
would use the language but I think
there's definitely a wider group of
black people that would feel like oh
it's really annoying that dreadlocks
have been part of my culture since I
grew up and in my family lots of people
have them and yet when I wear them
people presume that I'm a drug dealer or
I've been a child has been sent home
from school because their hair is in
dreadlocks and so again I think if we
had a fairer society in a fairer system
where you know people wouldn't be
praised or celebrated for doing things
that other people have been
discriminated against for a long time
then the debate would really calm down
and cease to exist given that anger has
served the black community well it was
the driving force behind much of the
civil rights movement it would be
difficult to abandon it entirely but as
that becomes less to be angry about his
anger the the best way to try and affect
change in a country in which the
majority of people would if they would
if they were cold racist be really
deeply offended and upset by that so I
think I mean what achievement is that
people although I think this might be
shifting a little but people are
embarrassed at least to be called racist
I mean people definitely weren't
embarrassed by the
in the 1960s you know people be like
okay fine yeah I am a racist whatever
and I'm glad that there's social
sanction around that I'm glad that their
shame I'm less glad that there seems to
be more shame around being called one
than the actions so I think there's a
bit of an issue there now where people
are embarrassed to be called a racist
but will still continue holding racist
beliefs and carrying out racist actions
but anger because I'm not answering a
question otherwise hmm
I think anger is really important I
don't want to be angry all the time
because it's exhausting but I think it
can be a driving force for change I
think we need that I think we need to be
angry about things otherwise we get
complacent